♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
AT THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
DOCTOR FOUTS G AND OTHER EXPERTS
TOLD A 60% OF AMERICA WOULD HAVE
TO BE VACCINATED BEFORE WE COULD
GET BACK TO NORMAL.
THEN IT BECAME 70% AND THEN 80%
AND NOW HE TELLS "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" IT COULD BE 90%.
AND HE ADMITTED HE’D BEEN
DELIBERATELY MOVING THE GOALPOST
BECAUSE AMERICA WASN’T READY TO
HEAR THE TRUTH.
WHETHER IT’S 60, 70, 80 OR 90 IS
ALL PART OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
VACCINE GROUP THINK AND IT IS
DANGEROUSLY WRONG.
IF WE JUST TARGET THE VULNERABLE
WE COULD AND LOCK DOWNS BY END
OF THIS MONTH BUT INSTEAD DOCTOR
FAUCI AND THE ESTABLISHMENT WANT
TO KEEP IT GOING DESPITE ALL THE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION THEY ARE
CAUSING.
SARAH, IT’S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME
-- DO REMEMBER IN THE BEGINNING
AND THOSE OF US WHO ARGUED
AGAINST THE LOCKDOWN SAID
THERE’S AN ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY
TO PROTECT THE VULNERABLE AND
THEN THEY WOULD SAY TO YOU, HOW
WILL YOU PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
AND WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
NOW WE HAVE HIGHLY SPECIFIC WAY
OF DOING IT I.E. THE VACCINE AND
THEY DON’T SEEM INTERESTED OR
CARE ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS
SCIENTIFICALLY JUSTIFIED BUT
SEEMS THEY JUST WANT TO KEEP
THIS LOCKDOWN GOING BECAUSE THEY
ARE IDEOLOGICALLY COMMITTED TO
IT.
>> THAT’S RIGHT, STEVE.
LOOK AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
YEAR WITH DOCTOR FAUCI AND THE
MASKS.
HE THINKS IT’S OKAY TO JUST SAY
WHATEVER COMES OUT OF HIS MOUTH
WHETHER IT’S THE TRUTH OR NOT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REMEMBER, IN THE BEGINNING HE
WOULD SAY NO, DON’T GO OUT AND
BUY MASKS AND IT’S NOT GOING TO
HELP YOU THAT MUCH AT ALL OR
HELP ANYONE AND MAKE SURE THEY
ARE OUT FOR THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS BUT THEN HE SAID I
DID NOT NEED TO SAY THAT AND I
WAS JUST TRYING TO SAVE THE
MASKS FOR THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS BEEN OUTLIVING THE
GOALPOST ALMOST 295%.
LOOK WHAT IS HAPPENING IN GREAT
BRITAIN AND IN CANADA AND THE
GENTLEMAN THAT WENT OUT AND
HUGGED PEOPLE IN THE STREET IN
FRONT OF THE POLICE AND THEN
THEY HANDCUFFED HIM.
THEY SAID HE WAS EXPOSING PEOPLE
AND PUTTING PEOPLE’S LIVES IN
DANGER.
THIS IS A TRAMPLING OF OUR
RIGHTS AND OUR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
HOW FAR WILL THIS GO AND IT’S
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING WE ALL NEED
TO THINK ABOUT THAT HOW FAR ARE
WE WILLING TO ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN BEFORE WE START
QUESTIONING AND SAYING WAIT ONE
MINUTE, WHEN IS ENOUGH AND
ENOUGH AND WHEN WILL WE GET THE
TRUTH FROM OUR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS?
STEVE: EXACTLY.
JANELLE, WHEN THE LOCKDOWNS
STARTED THE JUSTIFICATION WAS
LOW, WE KNOW FROM THE DATA THAT
MOST PEOPLE WHO GET THIS WILL BE
FINE AND HAVE MILD OR ZERO
SYMPTOMS BUT OBVIOUSLY AS WE
KNOW IT’S INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
FOR SMALL PROPORTION AND THEY
MADE IT CLEAR THAT’S HEALTHY
PEOPLE.
EVEN THOUGH YOU MAY NOT BE AT
RISK WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT YOU
TAKING IT HOME TO GRANDMA AND
INFECTING HER.
IF WE CAN AND VACCINATE GRANDMA
AND GRANDPA AND THE PEOPLE AT
RISK THAN THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE LOCKDOWNS FALLS AWAY BUT
THERE IS NO ACCEPTANCE OF THAT.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THAT’S COMPLETELY RIGHT.
IT’S ALMOST LIKE THEY WANT TO
COMPLETELY DESTROY THIS ECONOMY
AND SAY YOU HAVE NOTHING LEFT
AND IT’S A SCARY THOUGHT.
I THINK THE BIGGEST ISSUE FOR ME
IS THAT THIS IS SOME ONE IN
GOVERNMENT WHO FEELS LIKE THEY
CAN MAKE DECISIONS FOR MY
HEALTHCARE MUCH BETTER THAN I
CAN FOR MYSELF AND HAVE YOU TOLD
US THE TRUTH AND LET US DECIDE
WHAT IS BEST WE PROBABLY WOULD
BE IN A DIFFERENT POSITION BUT
INSTEAD HE DECIDED THAT IT’S
BETTER TO LIGHT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND BE UNTRUTHFUL VERSUS
ALLOWING US TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS.
TO YOUR POINT, THE ECONOMY IS
WHAT IS TAKING THE HIT AND THE
SMALL BUSINESSES, RESTAURANTS,
WE TALKED TO A RESTAURANT OWNER
JUST THIS PAST WEEKEND WHO HAD
TO SHUT DOWN ONE OF HIS
RESTAURANTS AND HE SAID HE WILL
NEVER PROBABLY REOPENED AND THEN
LOST HALF OF HIS STAFF.
THE LEVEL OF STRESS THAT IS
CAUSING OUR BUSINESS OWNERS IN
THE ECONOMY THAT IT’S
UNBELIEVABLE AND SAD THAT WE ARE
THAT DR. FAUCI IS NOT GIVING THE
SAME LEVEL OF CRITICISM THEY
GIVE THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE MADE A
STRONG DECISION WITHOUT JUMPING
TO CONCLUSIONS.
STEVE: THE OTHER ASPECT OF THIS
VACCINE I’M NOTICING IS HOW THE
REST OF THE MEDIA JUST DESPERATE
TO TRY TO FIND ANYWAY TO
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT TRUMP, EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS HIS ACTION THAT
BROUGHT US THE VACCINE SO
QUICKLY.
THEY ARE SAYING THE ROLLOUT IS A
DISASTER SO LET’S JUST PUT UP
THE DATA ON THIS WHICH SHOWS THE
PROPORTION OF POPULATIONS OF
CERTAIN COUNTRIES, LARGE
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
VACCINATED.
THIS IS A TABLE THAT THE U.S. IS
AT THE TOP OF AND THE ONLY OTHER
MAJOR COUNTRY DOING BETTER THAN
US RIGHT NOW TERMS OF
VACCINATION IS THE UK AND THEY
APPROVED THE VACCINE OF COURSE
THESE BEFORE WE DID AND WE
RAPIDLY ARE CATCHING UP AND
SEEMS TO ME THEY ARE LITERALLY
NOT PREPARED TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT CREDIT FOR ANYTHING
AND THEY JUST WANT TO HIT THEM
EVERY WAY THEY CAN, EVEN WHEN
THE FACTS DON’T JUSTIFY IT.
>> YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT IT WAS
DOCTOR ANTHONY FAUCI WHO SAID IT
WOULD BE 18 MONTHS AT A MINIMUM
BEFORE WE WOULD EVEN HAVE A
VACCINE BUT AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THE PRESIDENT’S FOCUS AND
MARSHALING OUR NATION’S GREAT
RESOURCES WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT TIME.
TURNS OUT DOCTOR ANTHONY FAUCI
IS A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL AND NOT
YODA AND NOT THE ORACLE OF ALL
THINGS TRUE OR FALSE AND BUT
YOU’RE RIGHT BE MEDICAL
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX IS A ZENITH
POWER BID THESE UNELECTED PEOPLE
HAVE THE POWER TO DEEM OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS ESSENTIAL OR
NONESSENTIAL AND CAN RACK AND
STACK DIFFERENT POPULATIONS OF
AMERICANS FOR PRIORITIZING THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION AND I FOUND
AN INTERESTING WEBSITE COVID
PREDICTOR .COM WHERE AMERICAN
INNOVATORS FOUND A WAY TO USE
YOUR DNA SEQUENCES ALONGSIDE
OTHER COMORBIDITIES AND
PREDICTORS TO ASCERTAIN WHAT
YOUR RISKS WOULD BE FOR COVID
USING SCIENCE AND IT WOULD BE
BETTER THAN USING POLITICS OR
JUST THE DESIRE OF GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONTROL OVER PEOPLE WHEN MAKING
THESE DECISIONS THAT ARE SO
CONSEQUENTIAL TO OUR LIVES.
STEVE: WELL, I MEAN, THAT IS SO
RIGHT.
YOU ALL MADE GREAT POINTS AND
WOULD KEEP FIGHTING THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT SEEMS LIKE WE
WILL KEEP FIGHTING IT FOR A LONG